mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschen ihnen viel vergnügen
diversity
diversität das stichwort der stunde in
kunst und theater ist das thema
omnipräsent es geht darum das macht
umverteilt wird
und das geht nie ab ohne konflikte weil
die die macht haben lassen die man gern
los weg mit den alten weißen hetero
männer her mit vielfalt muss das sein
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz ja die
diversity debatte treibt uns heute um es
geht um herkunft um unsere sexualität
ums geschlecht und um so vieles mehr und
diese diversity debatte sie interessiert
uns weil sie richtig hohe wellen schlägt
und sie auch gesellschaftspolitisch
relevant ist station machen wie hier in
der ausstellung quer im
naturhistorischen museum in bern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja da war city ist das wort der stunde
und vor allem auf theaterbühnen wird das
momentan auf allen ebenen erprobt
beklatscht und auch bekämpft wir fragen
was passiert wenn identitätspolitik den
inhalt auf theaterbühnen bestimmt und
ihr treffen das schweizer model thermik
lauser so was wie ein role model für
diversity
[Musik]
sie ist mister varsity thermik lauser
lesbischen binär und schweizer model mit
nigerianischen wurzeln ein phänomen
ihrer zeit dass sich weder auf eine
herkunft noch auf ein geschlecht
festlegen will
am anfang ihrer karriere steht das spiel
mit den geschlechtern model zu werden so
androgyn wie sie war erst eine
herausforderung dann eine chance
gerade vielleicht oft schwierig sehen
und vorstellungen von mit 27 ja
nicht unbedingt wie die anleger deshalb
ist zum beispiel kosten von
22 und eine chance die angedienten
natalie seine damals angesagt und
nachhaltigkeit
[Gelächter]
sie fand ihre geschlechtszugehörigkeit
dazwischen zwischen frau und mann und
entspricht damit voll den zeitgeist
[Musik]
nicht mit das so werde mit meiner frau
identifiziert orte ja noch damit
beschäftigt sache
wahrscheinlich
zum beispiel bip war sowie turnieren der
welt klang
wie
ein ganz großer
sender fluid nennt man das wo die
grenzen zwischen den geschlechtern auch
verschwimmen können als was sich jemand
fühlt und angesprochen werden will
wollen heute alle selbst entscheiden
das ist auch eine forderung der
studierenden an der zürcher hochschule
der künste
ansprache muss verhandelt werden damit
sie niemanden ausschließt sagt der
studierenden sprecher der zhdk
das thema ich sehe da es gibt mit wieder
unterricht wo wir uns mit pronomen
vorstellen die wellen pronomen max aber
möchte die aussprache werde und dass das
sind da versucht das heißt zur
normalität machen dass man über die
themen geredet und dass das nicht das
tabuthema ist über sind die sexualität
über das geschlecht so vernetzen
doch das führt zu konflikten
denn nicht alle dozierenden wänden
gender gerechte ansprache an
meinen dozenten dozentin studentin mit
wort mit
das schon diskriminierend und ich finde
dass ich absolut hochschulen und trefft
oder so
in der debatte um gender zugehörigkeit
geht es auch um diversität des stoffes
der im unterricht behandelt wird
diversität heißt auch die autoren des
lehrstoffes sollten nicht immer männlich
und eurozentrische sein
es ist definitiv so dass
man keinen letzten 30 jahre
wieso man sich praktisch und muss mit
perspektive wenn ich in erster linie
wichtig dass man
neue randgruppe wo bisher bin ich noch
nicht so behandelt wird und platz gibt
dass das detail stimmt zu es
[Musik]
ist ein konflikt zwischen
identitätspolitik und bildungsauftrag
gibt es tatsächlich dass man sich nicht
versteht also dass die jungen
gut aber aussieht in ihre traditionelle
sprach vielleicht vermittler daher
konflikt oder das konfliktpotenzial
[Musik]
das braucht auch
[Applaus]
am schauspielhaus zürich findet ein
umdenken statt
mehr diverse und neue stimmen auch in
klassischen stoffen
antworten als geschichte der
germanischen götter wird exemplarisch
identitätspolitik verhandelt
[Applaus]
neurologen die welt nicht mehr begreift
sagt hier alles wird unübersichtlich
die puste aus gesagt hier
[Musik]
der deutsche autor negative siri hat die
heldensaga zu einem protest stück gegen
unterdrückung und neue machtverhältnisse
umgeschrieben es kommen die zu wort die
sonst nur nebenrollen spielen wenn
überhaupt
wir uns wohl drauf zu sein brauchen sie
euer zuhause auf den trainer zu sein was
die freude auf das leben das wir nicht
haben in diesem tag die türen der busse
die mutti ist am morgen der schweiz
unsere eltern diese wurde durch arbeit
erst vor einer woche sind die käufer von
anderen
damit ich die kehrseite der geschichte
erzählen können damit ich die geschichte
erzählen kann aus der perspektive der
verlierer in meinem fall sind das ganz
klar fragen von
verteilung von ressourcen
vor dem hintergrund dass vor allem
sogenannte gastarbeiter in unsere heimat
aufgebaut haben und wer hat eigentlich
welchen preis dafür bezahlt
das schauspielhaus zürich setzt voll auf
diverses theater
chorleiter benjamin von blomberg
verknüpft die klassiker mit den
aktuellen politischen debatten und
bespielt damit seine bühne
es gibt gerade stoffe die brennen und
die sind da und die treiben uns alle um
und diese frage gerade danach wie lange
vielleicht strukturen gewisse menschen
ausgeschlossen haben und plötzlich sind
die da sie sehr mit uns alle verändert
hat wie sehr blackwater uns alle
verändert hat dass diese dinge sind
jetzt da sie zu ignorieren wäre falsch
für ein medium das sehr so sehr auch in
der gegenwart sein möchte
warten das personal wird vom himmel auf
den boden der heutigen realität geholt
wotan der mächtigste der alten götter
versucht dabei verzweifelt sich an der
macht festzukrallen
heute werde der bürger dieser armen
sauge überhaupt 1000 wollen die brücke
jetzt jung ich bin 43 wird absolut sagen
ich bin auch eine weitere position denn
man lebt von sich selbst was das heißt
dass man plötzlich aus der reserve
gelockt wird weil man bisher gedacht hat
man hat irgendwie dinge die auch durch
drohungen und verstand und hat eine
meinung dazu und plötzlich aus der
reserve gelockt und was macht dass das
mal aus der reserve gelockt wird
zementiert man damit die eigene meinung
und sagt sie lauter und auf die gleiche
art und weise die man schon immer hatte
oder fängt mal anzuhören und zu schauen
was verändert sich das zeitlich an den
blick
der weiße mensch macht euch nicht so
viel gedanken da kommt auch noch weiter
vor natürlich nicht so wahnsinnig wie
sorgen auch in der welt macht euch nicht
so viele gedanken und die weiße menschen
und auch bei unserem theater ich bin
noch da ist sind viele da du bist da
keine sorge das was wir akzeptieren
müssen dass menschen dazu kommen die wir
lange ausgeblendet haben
und dass das nicht ohne konflikte abgeht
ist völlig klar es
braucht veränderung damit neue
geschichten unterschiedlicher herkunft
die covers dieser welt küren
geschichten die bisher kaum platz hatten
um überhaupt stattzufinden
der mediziner hat mit dem namen ping und
wird dann das gibt dem sommer die kritik
die man sich einfach so aufbau gemacht
da nicht normal sondern einfach irgendwo
herkommen
durch zufall
bin sofort
erkennbar
[Musik]
in dieser debatte rund um diversity
liegt richtig viel schafft aber wenn
wundert sie verläuft auch nicht ganz
reibungslos die deutsche
kulturwissenschaftlerin mit susan
erkennt diese auseinandersetzung schon
länger als kind in die polnische eltern
ist sie es seit jeher gewohnt anders zu
sein divers mein kollege labbadia wollte
von ihr wissen wo wir denn aktuell
stehen in dieser debatte
medusa real ist kulturwissenschaftlerin
und schriftstellerin
ihr roman identität eroberte letztes
jahr die bestseller listen es ist die
geschichte einer professorin die vorgibt
enkelin zu sein aber in wahrheit weiß
ist
dann ja als buch erzählt sehr humorvoll
von
identitätskonflikte zugehörigkeit und
diversität mit sozial woher kommen sie
eigentlich ich nehme diese frage wurde
ihnen und wird ihn wahrscheinlich
ziemlich oft gestellt was löst denn
diese frage in ihnen aus ursprünglich
war es für mich tatsächlich eine
existenzielle frage auf die es niemals
eine richtige antwort gab also wenn ich
gesagt habe als deutschland haben alle
immer gesagt aber wo kommst du wirklich
her das problem war ja auch dass leute
in meiner antwort nicht geglaubt haben
als ich mich die autorität über die
antwort war seien die fragen immer so
lang weiter gefragt haben bis sich die
richtige antwort gegeben haben und wenn
ich gesagt haben ja ich komme aus
oberbilk ich komme aus düsseldorf aber
ich frag jetzt weiter bis du sagst warum
so braun wirst was ist eigentlich
diversität für sie ist das ein gefühl
eine haltung ein versprechen
der diversität ist ja eine politische
willenserklärung wird dass wir sagen wir
finden es wichtig dass menschen mit in
wie sogenanntem migrationshintergrund
ebenfalls in einer in einer sinnvollen
und um die angemessenen form darin
vertreten sind weil wir das versprechen
ist ja dass die künste sozusagen der
spiegel der gesellschaft sind und wenn
sie aber die gesellschaften spiegeln
sondern eine ausschließlich weiße
gesellschaft spiegeln dann erfüllen sie
ja nicht ihren zweck diversität hat im
moment ja gerade so naht hochkonjunktur
haben wir in der kultura sozialer fehlen
mode alles soll und muss die wehr sein
an welchen punkt stehen wir denn da aus
ihrer sicht in dieser debatte naja ich
glaube im moment was hochkonjunktur hat
es der wunsch nach diversität weil die
facto es ist ja nicht so wenn man sich
die deutschen aus anguckt an den
theatern zum beispiel wenn niemand sie
überhaupt nicht diverse und deshalb wir
ihn jetzt zum ersten mal darüber zu
sagen das kann jetzt ja nicht wirklich
zufällig so sein es ist ja nicht so dass
schwarz und braun menschen schlechtere
schauspieler sind was sie natürlich
machen müssen ist bei der
voraussetzungen ansetzen okay was ist
mit den schauspielschulen was ist auch
damit was menschen sich vorstellen
können zu machen also welche in die
berufswege können menschen sich
vorstellen zu machen und das ist ja
super interessant dass gerade der
migrationsforschung das irgendwie den
kindern von migranten migrantinnen immer
gesagt hat ihr müsst einen ganz sicheren
beruf haben das sind eltern die halt
alles aufgegeben haben die suche nach
ewiger sicherheit für ihre kinder und
diesen kindern möglichkeit zu gehen
müsst ihr nicht ihr könnt auch
künstlerische berufe haben ihr werdet
über lieben es wird okay sein aber ist
denn so die pläne der film die kultur
ist das der richtige ort für so
identitäts politische verbindung
debatten
also natürlich die kunst stellt ja immer
die frage der billig das ist ja genau
der ort wo sich wie eine gesellschaft
selbst erzählt wer sie ist es geht ja
immer um identität es geht immer darum
wie vororte ich mich ganz lange also
muss ich meinen roman geschrieben habe
habe ich menschen wie mich nicht in der
deutschsprachigen literatur
repräsentiert gefühlt also mixed race
menschen gab es in der deutschsprachigen
literatur nicht gibt viele menschen die
sagen ich bin diversity für affen aber
bei der sprache da hört es auf können
sie sich erklären warum das so ist der
wald sprache ja das ist was wir immer
verwenden wir können ja nicht sagt habe
ich feierabend jetzt spreche ich mal
nicht mehr entsprach also sprach ist ja
wirklich so das mittel mit denen wir uns
in der welt verorten und auch vor
reflektiert also überlegen uns nicht vor
jedem satz was wir sagen und das heißt
veränderungen merken wir auch wirklich
schmerzhaft daran sprach ist das was
kontakt herstellen und wenn mir dann
jemand sagt das war falsch gesagt bricht
der kontakt ab und das tut weh das so
körperlich wie das kann man messen das
problem mit metronom ist dass die
deutschen unglaublichen er ist also wir
haben auch noch irgendwie neutrum aber
dass benutzer natürlich nicht menschen
aber irgendwie deshalb irgendwie sagen
halt immer das geschlecht mit dazu ich
kann verstehen dass es menschen schwer
fällt aber ich lerne jeden tag eine neue
sprache ich habe gelernt denn hier das
irgendwie eine wasser pcr-test es ich
habe gelernt irgendwie wie das akronym
für diese masken ist fsp zwei masten da
habe ich richtig lange dafür gebraucht
das war richtig schnell die sprache
bestimmt das sein und das sein bestimmt
das bewusstsein und beides stimmt und
beides hat wechselwirkungen aufeinander
vielen dank für die zeit und für das
gespräch mitchells ein jahr
die ausstellung im naturhistorischen
museum zeigt auf wie viel coolness es im
tierreich gibt
kröten werden altus weiblich also die
hier mit als man trifft wartung mit dem
alter werden wer zwiebeln
egoist traums
stirbt es verwandelt sich das größte
menschen in ein weibchen
[Musik]
es gibt mehr tiere menschen aus
selbständiger
das heißt das leben über
630.000 kühle menschen in der schweiz
von den tieren schlägt die ausstellung
den bogen zur gesellschaft thematisiert
wie geschlecht entsteht wie vielfältig
sexualität sein kann und mit welchen
vorurteilen quere menschen konfrontiert
sind
letzte woche da erzählte mir eine
freundin ihre 15-jährige tochter sei
jetzt nicht mehr lisa sondern alex und
wolle ab sofort als neue binäres wesen
respektiert und auch so angesprochen
werden nur wie funktioniert das dann im
alltag mit der ansprache ist das nicht
viel zu kompliziert oder aber im
gegenteil entscheidend damit sich
bestehende machtverhältnisse verändern
können denn sprache das ist klar ist
auch macht
nicht er oder sie
nicht viele menschen identifizieren sich
nicht oder nur teilweise mit dem
männlichen oder dem weiblichen
geschlecht
so möchten sie auch angesprochen werden
ohne geschlecht bezeichnung wie herr
müller oder mit neutralen pronomen in
diesem beitrag werden deshalb nur die
vornamen verwendet
sascha eickel braucht meistens keine
blumen für sich
für nicht binäre personen kann die
pronomen wahl einen wichtigen inneren
prozess bedeuten
[Musik]
die haben ganz langen ossi pro nummer
für mich braucht und das hat mich nicht
groß gestört
es hat mir dann aber immer mehr belastet
das haut glück wie selbstverständlich
als frau lasse und dass sie eigentlich
tun hat der nette schlags oder der rasse
wie es zeigt und das hat mit einer
oder zuletzt die bewusst fertig und das
in jedem moment ohne dass eine
tolerierung auch in die unterwerfung
immer dass ich das okay finde das echt
klasse und versprach licht wird also
[Musik]
henrik amalia von dewitz ist nicht binär
und zurzeit lehrperson in luzern
mit einer eher für mich aufgrund von
ausgesehen hat wie sind nicht und lasse
stellen wenig entgegen grundsätzlich
finde ich natürlich ich lade zum henn
und sie brauchen das braucht wird auch
wenn henrik amalia männliche aussieht
beschreibt das pronomen sieg ebenfalls
henrik amalias geschlechtsidentität
die irritation ist henrik amalia bewusst
die schüler/innen sprechen henry canaria
als person von dewitz an ich habe mich
so versöhnlich ist ferner im alltag und
in einer verschiedenen sphären eingang
ist oder dass mit bruno
jetzt jede schule wo gerade die realität
ist negative finde
mache ich es gar nicht zum thema das
also ich bin's indirekt thematisiert er
mich meine arbeit dann kommunizieren
meine arbeit ist nicht herr oder frau
also die zwei optionen sondern person
das ist für mich die neutrale option was
ich für mich wohler fühlt
im alltag ist oft kein raum und keine
zeit für erklärung
doch eine andere zuordnung kann für
nichtlineare verletzend sein
[Musik]
in der gastronomie ist es halt so dass
sie ständig kontakt haben wir glück und
die automatisch und sofort die lacher
und in der regel nicht hinterfragen
lassen wie es mit dem überraschten und
wenig metern tiefe zieren und da
passiert es dann halt oft das lied den
madame oder irgendwie letztlich hat
einige seiten ihren hund lockt das
schöne frauen auch
unternehmer sondieren
welche position infrage platziert soll
ich sagen
circa 35.000 nicht binärer leben in der
schweiz das entspricht der einwohnerzahl
des kantons uri anstatt er oder sie geht
ins kino könnte man zum beispiel sagen
peres für person geht ins kino oder max
geht ins kino der max filme mag
unbestritten eine herausforderung für
die deutschen sprache und die
gesellschaft henryk amalia versteht es
gut was ich bin nicht stark ist während
pädophilie ist hey
du macht magath bis negatives oder du
nämlich noch gar nicht erwünscht und
wenn die person wieder den soli sei und
wie sie darauf besteht und das ist es
auch wieder nicht wieso findet ihr hier
seid ja davon offene fehlerkultur haben
also es ist doch völlig okay dass ich
sage ich fühle mich wohl und das ist
völlig okay dass du es hätte mit dem
überfordert wenn ich wenn ich diese
lautsprecher
[Musik]
selbst in der community ist man sich
noch nicht einig über eine verbindliche
finale regelung der ansprache
grundsätzlich braucht einfach frau meint
reese bildungsauftrag aus gesellschaft
und mit einem eine nette kulisse bilden
und allen online erwarten sondern dass
sich glücklich mit dem thema
auseinandersetzen / du das genauso die
gender waren reflexe völlig abgebaut
werden und das mit eigentlich dieser
dialog kann man mit ein anderes
verständnis und eine offenheit und
frauen inklusive gedanken oder das
inklusiv bedürfnis für diese etablieren
und das den anspruch nach suchen
sprache ist macht sie inkludiert kann
aber auch ausschließen und schafft damit
realitäten
[Musik]
jetzt wollen wir ihnen lebendig
vorstellen aus non binäre
kunstschaffende person ist bandic die
sache mit dem pronomen genauso
nebensache wie selbstverständlichkeit
jedenfalls hat bandic die performance
für sich entdeckt viele davon stammen
von marina abramovic und damit lotet
lebendig die grenzen des menschlichen
daseins aus
kam in ihrer längste performance 12 tag
um 12 nacht im museum
klasse nur wasser trinken
dreimal am tag dusche teile der klasse
geschrieben wird grundsätzlich wirklich
dass man sich den 3 grube wolle bald
über hannes geliebt
mein name ist eine kunst schafften die
person bewegt
weil ich vor allem natürlich sehr
konzentriert sehr brisant sehr die
performance ist performance wofür es
statt gefunden hat wo widerruft führte
ich habe sehr viele verschiedene
performances von der marina abramovic
gemacht ich habe vom
immobilienmarkt immer mit ihrer
stadtmitte meckern über ganz neue und zu
bekommen muss ich für die druck- und
entweder auf die eltern auf die andere
seite 3 der friedenskuss wo man redet
bis dato merab schritt bis man stimme
hat dann ist er kaputt geht luna city wo
man nackt in drei meter höhe vom velo
sattel hockt und langsam therme und
aufgeweckt haus videos zwölf tage lang
und zwölf nacht
leer als willkommene und hätte
mit denen mancher kann wo man die
batterien wieder aufgeladen hätte ich
das nie geschafft
luft nicht schmecken
bundesmittel walzer der kassen stunden
konnten sie ihre kunden ich habe gewisse
gedanken birgt obsessiv ständig sind sie
wieder offen ich weiß dass ich sie nicht
spezifisch lust auf diablo und ram
und ein gedanken habe immer wieder
beschäftigt hat ist die wirklich
wahnsinnig wie weiß auch dass rezent
wahnsinnig wird
ich glaube viel vor der marina ihre
arbeit und am innere grenze nach ungarn
und der europa ständiger seine ganze
psychisch physisch mental als mensch als
künstlerin und irgendwann merken dass wo
immer du mein krampf
im beispiel von der marina was film
selbst 40 gramm zu kaufen körperliche
ich verstanden wie sie dankt will ein
körperlich nur ein teil vom land ich
glaube ihre art ist extrem suchen und
schmerzpunkte
überwinden irgendwann war nur dass man
oft macht ein spielerisches nehmen
natürlich ist es vielleicht aus sagte
struck tief aber das ist außerhalb
struck tief tritt zur stunde am tag vorm
bildschirm zocken das ist außerhalb
struck tief komische die das machen und
ständig medienbilder grund zu mir waren
gut sind
die reform ist das mache ich für mich
ein space bis anhin nicht komplett über
mich als performance ausland
beschluss ist wahnsinnig emotional sagte
ich mir alles so viel zählt sie
überhaupt wieder runter und laufe und
aufwärts ohne hat so einen vermerk immer
sofort
ich glaube dass man mir am meisten
blieben ist ich das gefühl hat weil
verletzlich und macht das andere lied
ein weiterer gemeinheit begegnet oder
tee trinken und europa region immer
wieder gemacht haben ist das wenn ich
offen auch machen auch die anderen und
das kreiert extrem schöne space wo mich
einfach wahnsinnig bewirkt hat
[Musik]
mein wunsch an eine künftige
gesellschaft leben und leben lassen mehr
liebe liebe viel liebe und toleranz
toleranz noch mehr toleranz ist
wahrscheinlich das am meisten genannte
wort hier an dieser wunsch wandern da
kann ich mir auch gleich selbst an der
nase nehmen in sachen toleranz in sachen
bewusstsein wie ausschließend wir
wahrscheinlich immer wieder sind
vielleicht ohne es zu merken aus
mehrheitsgesellschaft minderheiten
gegenüber
[Musik]
der nächste woche übernimmt hier nina
mails brunner und trifft büne huber der
mit patent ochsner als erster schweizer
band bei mtv unplugged gefeatured wurde
gleich jetzt geht es weiter mit der
stärkung der philosophie zum thema
globalisierung wir sehen uns im märz
wider tschüss
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]